bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors la cote de popularité
de joe biden est en chute libre un il
perd 7 points dans les sondages qu'est
ce qu'on reproche précisément au
président américain sa décision de
maintenir le départ des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan où le chaos
que ce départ a suscité dans le pays
dont on lui reproche la manière on lui
reproche la façon dont il a géré cette
manoeuvre les américains étaient et
demeurent je pense très favorable à un
retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan
mais ils ne sont pas favorables au chaos
et ce à quoi ils ont assisté depuis
trois-quatre jours les a tellement
surpris c'est une telle douche froide ce
sont des images qui sont tellement
terrible en plus parce qu'elle évoque
d'autres images la fuite de de ces gens
qui cherchent à monter dans ce c 17
américains sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
ssa a rappelé les gens qui cherchaient à
fuir saigon il ya 40 ans lors de la
guerre du vietnam donc ce sont des
images que les américains ont déjà vu
qui leur rappelle une période où
l'amérique elle est très très mal et
donc ce qu'ils reprochent à leur
présidence c'est vraiment cette très
mauvaise gestion de cette crise le
départ des troupes américaines
devait se faire de manière ordonnée et
de manière sécurisée et c'est pas du
tout ce qui s'est passé du coup les
américains se rendent compte que leur
gouvernement ou leur président n'est pas
au courant de ce qui se passe et que ses
conseillers ne savent pas gérer une
situation rappelons que la politique
internationale c'est supposé être le
point fort de joe biden et que l'armée
américaine
c'est le symbole de sa puissance et
c'est une institution en laquelle les
américains ont encore confiance est là
ils ont un président qui est aux abonnés
absents qui blâment tout le monde sauf
lui même et ils ont une armée qui est
impuissante donc inévitablement ça ne
passe pas ils auraient ils auraient dû
anticiper joe biden la situation de
quelle manière
le plus simple à faire enfin le plus
simple ce qu'il fallait faire c'était
terminé l'évacuation avant qu'il y ait
un quelconque changement de pouvoir à
kaboul ce qui s'est produit ce qui s'est
produit c'est que l'offensive des
talibans a été beaucoup plus rapide que
les conseillers de dub hayden l'avait
envisagé je rappelle que le mois dernier
monsieur le général mark healey le
général par pin s est quand même de chef
d état major interarmées indiqué qu'
après le départ des américains
dans la possibilité d'un conflit entre
les forces afghanes et les talibans la
victoire des talibans n'était pas
garantie et non seulement on a eu une
victoire garantie mais elle s'est fait
en six jours et elle s'est faite sans
combattre les américains disent avoir
été surpris par ce comportement des
forces afghanes qui n'ont pas combattu
mais ses forces elles ont été formées
par eux mêmes donc quelque part il y a
eu soit une série de mensonges quant à
la qualité de ses forces armées soient
des illusions qui ont été entretenues
par les politiques mais à l'évidence il
ya quelque chose qui ne s'est pas passé
tels que ça aurait dû se passer et les
américains le découvre et il se pose des
questions sur la capacité de leurs
gouvernants à gouverner ce que joe biden
a fait avec l'afghanistan et mythique
cela restera comme l'une des plus
grandes défaites dans l'histoire
américaine alors ses propos et son
signèrent donald trump l'ancien
président qui a d'ailleurs appelé à la
démission de son successeur donald trump
qui fait du donald trump là où est ce
qu'il a à raison joe biden est considéré
comme le principal responsable de cette
fin de guerre
je vais aux etats unis quand il ya une
expression américaine qui dit the box
tops speer ça veut dire que quand on est
responsable
eh bien on assume la responsabilité et
le responsable ultime celle président
maintenant ce qui est intéressant dans
ce que vous avez dit c'est que
aujourd'hui trempe n'est absolument pas
le seul à utiliser de tels propos dans
le reportage que vous avez montré ya
quelques instants il y avait une
situation terrible du new york times le
new york times est un organe de presse
qui jusqu'à présent a défendu baden vous
auriez pu citer s'y adonnent yen a eu
des mots extrêmement sévère avec baden
parlant de fiasco de catastrophes de
débâcle d'une tâche qu'ils allaient
rester sur une présidence qui a déjà
connu des crises est ce ce à quoi on est
en train de de
d'observer aux états unis c'est que
justement jusqu'à présent joe biden a
été protégé par les médias il a été
épargné il a été épargné tout au long de
la campagne électorale et il a été
largement épargnée depuis qu'il est
rentré à la maison blanche et on assiste
depuis la chute de kaboul bien une sorte
de retournement des médias et si demain
cnn si le washington post et le new york
times commence à être beaucoup plus
sévère avec le président ce qu'ils
auraient d'ailleurs dû faire depuis déjà
longtemps
inévitablement cela va rebondir sur son
image donc voir sa cote de popularité
s'effondrer aujourd'hui ce n'est
absolument pas surprenant et ce qui est
plutôt intéressant c'est de voir que les
propos de trunks sont partagées par des
médias qui n'ont jamais soutenu trump
cette victoire rapide des talibans
est-ce qu'elle remet en question la
poigne américaine son statut de gendarme
du monde selon vous où absolument mais
ça c'était c'était déjà le cas si vous
voulez les américains ont une expression
il parle de nationwide
c'est à dire de construire des états et
en gros l'idée de l'occupation de
l'afghanistan après en avoir chassé le
gouvernement taliban déjà en 2001
c'était de mettre en place des
structures solides d'inspiration si non
démocratique au moins on va dire
parlementaire et républicaine de faire
de l'afghanistan nous sommes à un failed
states c'est à dire un état en faillite
mais un état solide qui soit capable de
se gérer dans la paix et pour cela il
fallait construire des institutions est
aussi former une armée et donc les
américains s'y sont attelés pendant un
certain temps très vite un certain
nombre de voix on dit ça ne fonctionne
pas et il faudrait arrêter vous pouvez
remonter dès 2004 2005 2006 et 2007 il
ya un certain nombre d'intervenants sur
le terrain qu'ils disent ce que nous
essayons de faire n'est pas possible
parce que culturellement ça ne
fonctionne pas les américains on insisté
jusqu'au moment où ils ont compris qu'il
n'y parviendrais pas et à partir de là
il fallait revenir en arrière et il
fallait sortir de manière aussi ordonné
aussi pacifique est aussi digne que
possible ça c'est bien tout ce qui s'est
passé malheureusement ça veut dire
qu'après 20 ans de guerre 165 mille
morts dont plus de 2400 américain
plusieurs milliers de milliards de
dollars de dépenses c'est retour à la
case départ tout ça pour rien
oui c'est très malheureux mais c'est
comme ça et c'est pourquoi je vous dis
le concept de de construire un état est
une idée que beaucoup d'américains
soutenait ya quelques temps et
aujourd'hui elle n'a plus du tout au cas
où aucune popularité aux états unis
c'était la grande idée des
néoconservateurs voilà il fallait il
fallait rendre le monde autour des états
unis démocratique parce que les
démocraties ne se font pas la guerre est
donc le meilleur moyen d'assurer la
sécurité des états unis
c'était de répondre la démocratie tout
autour et les américains viennent de se
rendre compte que ce n'était pas
possible ça n'a pas été possible en irak
ça n'a pas été possible en afghanistan
et à partir de là c'est toute leur
stratégie à long terme qui va être
remise en cause gérald indivise et merci
pour cet éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste franco américain et
chercheurs alips